hi i'm dan radcliffe and i am back again
for a wired autocomplete part two
it's weird watching yourself as a kid
oh was it great okay so i'm consistent
oh so this is a test
this is what daniel radcliffe okay what
is daniel radcliffe's
favorite harry potter i actually love
the fifth one which is not one that most
people cite as one of their favorites
but i got to work with gary oldman a
bunch in it and
i was sort of a little bit older at that
point so i was kind of able to
appreciate that more but to watch
probably the last one what is daniel
radcliffe age i recently turned 32 when
i tell people that i'm 30 people just
they go sort of pale and look like the
inception with the you know on the beach
at the end when they've aged a thousand
years it's like that what
plays has daniel radcliffe
been in i did a play called equus um
which people probably know as being the
play about a psychologically disturbed
kid who is obsessed with horses and gets
naked that's the detail you probably
remember i did that when i was 17 which
seems crazy to say out loud now but i
did i did a play by martin mcdonough uh
called the of finnish man that
was a lot of fun i did a musical called
how to succeed in business without
really trying i'm just i'm just
listening my cv for you now but that's
fine i want to go back to broadway at
some point um and and the west end oh
and i did end game i did end game in
london
it's right before the pandemic as well
it's the most recent that's embarrassing
that i forgot that one i love i love
film as well but like stage you get a
pure adrenaline rush every night which
is really really exciting and addictive
what is what is daniel radcliffe's
accent i mean english just like kind of
boring middle of the road english that
means london i guess i've really been
told that my american accent which is
what comes out when i do an american
accent i've been told i sound like i'm
from ohio quite consistently i don't
even really know what that means but i
do know that chris columbus who was
directed the first two potters i think
he's also from ohio so maybe in some way
i'm just kind of mirroring the american
accent i heard the most growing up but
my own accent is just boring boring
english
who daniel radcliffe who does daniel
radcliffe
support
i'm assuming this means you know uh in
terms of sports and not like emotionally
i have become like an avid fan of many
american sports my loyalties in terms of
rooting interests are generally split
between new york teams and detroit teams
because my girlfriend is from just
outside detroit yeah i'm like a red
wings hockey fan and detroit lions
but also you know the giants and rangers
and obviously england in anything that
we're even remotely competitive in the
football team that i grew up supporting
in the uk is full of football club but
yeah i'm a much less big soccer fan than
you would expect from an english person
who
voices
daniel radcliffe
in bodak horsemen
me
um i did it yeah it would have been
actually an amazing
considering what the the episode the
joke that that episode ends with if if
they had had elijah would voice me in
that but they did not who does daniel
radcliffe
look like oh a perfect segue the idea of
me and elijah wood is the same we don't
actually look that alike but if you
imagine all our component parts we're
just sort of short pale
blue-eyed big-eyed brown-haired people
who does
elijah wood look like see above i
suppose i would love to be an immigrant
with elijah at this point it feels like
it would have to be something that is
consciously using the way the world sees
us as linked and and you know uh similar
looking i'm very open to pitches uh
there's no way you can do that because
i'm not on social media but you know if
it's good it'll get to me is that
irritative okay is daniel radcliffe
in cursed child no i'm i'm not that is
the the harry potter play i'm not in it
i haven't actually seen it as well not
because of the content of the play but
just because
i imagine the crowd would lean towards
big harry potter fans in a really
significant way so i i feel like being
in there just might be like people might
be watching me watch it and that's that
feels weird i've heard it is absolutely
fantastic though and everybody who has
goes has a wonderful time is daniel
radcliffe knighted
no
very much not that is very very far from
from a thing that i am or will ever be i
i would imagine
is daniel rad that's great that is
truly unexpected
is daniel radcliffe the geico gecko
no i mean i think i think that
advertising campaign pre-existed at a
time where i would be doing voice-over
work just because i think i would
probably sound like a teenager at the
time there's a thing in the ad that
always really annoys me when when he's
like people don't know if i'm english or
australian it's like no you're obviously
english you sound very english you would
know that uh no i'm not the gekko and i
obviously have other thoughts about it
which i'm just discovering now as well
is dana radcliff a time traveler
i can't talk about this here no i i
think this refers to a
an amazing quality that apparently my
face has it crops up in old photos a lot
a lot of the photos also have sort of
harry potter-ish glasses on but there
are truly are some of them that are just
eerie they found one of like an old lady
in like a bonnet i think and glasses it
is insane how much i look like this old
woman but if i was i wouldn't be able to
reveal that information because i would
screw up like the future is daniel
reichler still friends with tom felton
yes absolutely we're all kind of all
over the place we don't see each other
much but yeah i'm still like in contact
with all of them and it's like like we
were all you know obviously text rupert
last year when he had his baby which is
truly insane and amazing i always say
we'll always be bonded by this thing
even if we don't like
kind of live in each other's pockets
anymore
thank you olivia
all right why daniel radcliffe that's a
great question in and of itself why did
daniel radcliffe become an actor i had
like expressed an interest in acting
when i was like five or six and then i
saw a comedy play that my mum took me to
and i turned around to her as like i
want to be an actor and she having been
an actor and not had the greatest
experience of it was like no you don't
want to do that and i didn't really
think about it again for a long time and
then they were auditioning people to
play david copperfield for the bbc more
as like a self-esteem thing they were
like maybe he can have an audition and
that just the experience of auditioning
will have been a thing that none of the
other kids in the class will have and
then on that project i worked with
maggie smith she played my aunt in that
and then it was her who i think
recommended me to the director for
potter so yes thank you maggie why is
daniel radcliffe walking dogs i assume
this refers to a photo of me on the set
of train wreck it was a set and i'm
playing a character i have not just
become a dog walker in in real life i i
was doing a play in new york it was the
crippled vintage man i think john
appetite came and saw it and came back
to my dressing room after and was like
would you be up for doing like a really
silly small cameo in this this movie i
thought he was just being kind of nice
and then he at some point he phoned me
and talked me through like what i would
be doing and yeah it was great it was
such a fun day and that photo my god
that photo went everywhere why did
daniel radcliffe
quit harry potter
oh oh punch is for you
i didn't quit they finished no i i
obviously did not quit and i and i would
not have because it was it was awesome i
am now done and now being done i do not
feel an urge to to rush back to it just
because it was um you know like it's a
gigantic
life-changing thing and i feel like
having come out of it i've i've managed
to like get my life in a in a level that
i kind of you know can manage and feels
dealable with but i also never say never
because that's a dumb thing to say why
is daniel radcliffe in halifax
last year i my girlfriend was shooting a
tv show in nova scotia and so
i was hanging out in halifax for like a
good long while like a couple of months
and i think people were really confused
but it also happened it happens all the
time because aaron's from flint in
michigan and whenever we go back there
people are just like i created a small
scene at
a bob evans in in
michigan but they also that bob evans
was so sweet like the press the local
press heard that i had been to this bob
evans and so they they phoned them up
and asked what i had and what i ate and
the bob evans no commented they said
like they wouldn't tell them as like a
matter of my privacy i was like that's
you didn't need to you could have told
them i had an omelet i wouldn't have
minded but it's really nice of you why
isn't daniel radcliff verified on
instagram because
i am not on instagram and the person who
if they're saying it's me
they are not telling the truth i commend
all of you out there who are
mentally strong enough to be on social
media all the time i am not one of those
people i would go
fully insane so yeah i'm i'm staying
staying off for now
thank you
does daniel radcliffe does daniel raghav
actually wear
glasses no as you can see from my face i
have not got contact lenses in either i
was prescribed glasses when i was really
young and i kept losing them and at a
certain point my parents were like you
can see right and i was like yeah fine
and they were like okay i think we're
good then the glasses like whenever i
play another character that has glasses
it's the most involved i get in props
ever because i'm just like we have to be
very specific about which glasses we're
choosing here and they cannot be
reminiscent of they cannot be perfectly
circular basically does daniel radcliffe
have tattoos not yet again i really do
want some but again i've been talking
about this for so long there will always
be like a makeup artist who i know who
will be like don't do it we have to
cover them and we secretly hate you for
it but
i think i'm gonna bite the bullet at
some point because i do i really like
them talk to me in 10 years when i am
covered just head to toe does daniel
radcliffe like being famous
some of these questions are simple some
of them are complicated
i like my job
a side effect of my job is that i'm
famous but generally speaking like when
you hear people say that they want to be
famous
and like anonymity is a really cool
thing like it's it allows you to
do a lot and make mistakes and like them
not feel like all very very high stakes
all the time and so there's yeah there's
definitely like
some parts of fame that are just
weird and that i've had to like grow
into realizing what they are because
they're all such a part of my life if
fame is the part of my job that i have
to like deal with to do my job i would
make that deal like ten times out of ten
like it's it's not even a question does
dana writer play minecraft minecraft and
and olivia rodrigo have been two of the
real like oh i'm old moments of recently
minecraft obviously a few years ago i
was playing with my my godson or
attempting to play and he was like
explaining it to me and i was saying all
the old person things of just like i
don't get it how is it a game when do we
when does it finish it seems very cool
just can't do it and then yeah olivia
rodriguez was the same thing where she
was like at the white house and i was
like oh
you're famous enough to be at the white
house and this is the first time i'm
hearing about you so but that's that i
completely accept that is that is on me
not anyone else but yeah they've been
real real watershed moments recently
does daniel reckon like anime you know i
think i would like anime a lot even now
i'm going am i even versed enough to
know what anime specifically refers to
like it's certain series right but like
is avatar the last airbender anime that
i'm into that was great i know it's a
lot more in-depth than that but yeah i i
don't i don't think i am but i probably
would be if i like really got into it
what's daniel radcliffe what is danielle
ryancliff's favorite movie there's a
movie called a matter of life and death
it was made by i think paul and press
burger in like 19 i was saying like 1952
and it's this magical realist story
about like a fighter pilot getting shot
down over the channel but then the
angels miss him in the chaos of war so
he has to like go to heaven and make a
case that he should be allowed to keep
living it's so imaginative and
fun and yeah you know in terms of like
films i have re-watched the most it's
probably the um ben foster led teen
movie get over it it was one of the
first films that my girlfriend and i
bonded over yeah it's like an incredible
car it's like ben foster kirsten dunst
mila kunis colin hanks like so many
people are in that martin short is
unbelievable in it great movie so two
very different films for you to check
out there what did daniel radcliffe
get in his gcses one a star two ways and
the rest bees it is funny how much at
the time you're like man these gcse
results they are going to matter forever
if you're currently revising for them or
studying for them i am so sorry it sucks
and it will be over soon what does
daniel radcliffe smell like hmm
i don't know because i smell myself all
the time i'd imagine coffee and probably
like in the summer just
sweat it's it's unpleasant probably what
did daniel radcliffe pull out
of
his
head in jungle so yeah there's a scene
in a film i did called jungle where my
character is a real person who got lost
in the jungle he realizes that there is
something
living under his skin and he has to get
rid of that it's a very very gross quite
hard to watch seen in the movie one of
my favorite prosthetics that i've ever
worn you could do the whole thing
practically of like open it and pull it
out sorry this is really gross i feel
like it's worth mentioning that in the
film we gave you one of them in real
life yossi had like
10 to 20 of them all over his body that
he had to get out one by one there's
just some things that happened to you
that were
so extreme that yeah we we
we went with like a slightly easier
version
daniel ragler this is just my name
can i marry daniel radcliffe you know no
i'm probably not
but but that doesn't mean you won't meet
someone great i i yeah i've always been
very uh
you know awkward around this question
but if you met me you'd be like ah no i
don't know that guy it's fine what is
daniel radcliffe up to these days the
third season of this very very funny
incredibly lovely show that i do called
miracle workers this season is is the
most insane we've ever done so far at
one point they called me into the
writers room on zoom and were like we
have something to pitch you and they're
like they don't do that normally like i
trust them they don't have to run stuff
by me but they were like you appear in
this crazy outfit and you do a disco
version of she'll be coming around the
mountain when she comes whilst like
twerking and voguing i'm not somebody
who's ever gonna
tamp down somebody else's creative
spirit so i was like yeah okay and i'm
game for something slightly crazy it's
one of the most insane things i've ever
shot also one of the most fun days i've
ever had on a film set i also just
finished filming a movie called the lost
city of d with channing tatum and sandra
bullock in dominican republic and it's
it's awesome it really is like i i hope
that cinemas are kind of up and going
again by then and people feel
comfortable doing that so that you know
it's a real like grab your friends on
some popcorn and cheer at the screen
like it's a really good fun movie how
many films has daniel radcliffe been in
ah that's a great question i don't know
i i at last the last time i counted it
was probably like he was mid-twenties
i look at like
like michael caine's imdb and he's been
in like more than a hundred movies i
think whenever you want motivating just
look at michael kane's imdb you go yeah
you can you can keep working if you want
to how many times did daniel radcliffe
break his
wand this is a rumor i would like to
disperse there is a thing that i
sometimes see on twitter that's like
when i am going on it to not have one
but look at other people's amazing fact
a weird trivia thing will pop up and
it'll be like downright have broke
a hundred ones or like 60 ones on set
it's not that many guys i used to like
uh use them in like a drum on my leg
with it the whole time and like be doing
that all the time and eventually you
know you sort of wear them down and and
they will break but yeah it's it wasn't
it wasn't as many as that i feel like
everyone got through a few and i was
probably 12 maximum absolute maximum of
20.
finally daniel radcliffe periodic table
i learned the tom lehrer song the
elements when i was like
16 or 17. i don't know why i was that
kind of teenager i love anything that's
like wordy and fast and a bit of a
challenge and i got to meet tom lehrer
one day the guy who wrote that song and
many other songs if you take anything
away from this go and just like download
an evening wasted with tom lehrer
there's
a lot of other stuff in there that is
truly uh holds up brilliantly today cool
the one that like riled me slightly i
was like why did he quit harry potter
i'm like is that a thing people are
thinking that happened but no that's
what's wonderful about this segment you
give me a chance to correct that so
thank you so much for having me back
wired